[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits got a little
leak you didn't like that you usually
say I'm link oh that's funny I'm not a
creature habit it's funny I mean it's a
pretty simple thing just go with it a
guy who starts just says welcome to your
biscuits I'm whatever my name is I'm not
a creature of habit I don't like to do
this it's really a huge yeah you're the
one that this is happening dude yeah
you're linked you what you ended up
saying leaked which a lot of people
think your name is leaked nice sprung a
little leak or whatever you know a lot
of people think your name is leaked no I
said I said sprung a little link oh you
did no because when you go to Starbucks
don't a lot of times they think is
leaked yes right this is a sore subject
no well so yeah just the other day
leaked when we we went to Lang Starbucks
with our wives remember this oh yeah my
wife whose name is Jessie said there's
like what's her name and she said Jessie
and she was like that's a cute name
now she's like she said Jess no you
didn't say it to the barista you turned
around and you said it to me and
Christie you were like I was like this
girl thinks Jesse's a cute name she must
not be from America and then we got the
we got the cup and it was what did you
what did she written she had written
like was it I was in the trying to go in
the bathroom it was like which doesn't
happen on Hollywood Boulevard so I just
waited outside of the bathroom was like
time and yeah back yes er jacksie or
something like that it was she was Jack
see Jack see Jack see she thought she
said Jack see which would be a cute name
anyway my name is Rhett by this we got a
real valuable of downtown down pillows
we are replaced that we're really
hurting tonight y'all this week at the
roundtable of dim lighting issue boy
your boys are gonna talk to each other
about horror movies we feel a little bit
differently about them hmm
we have some different experiences and
interestingly we were like first-ever
and horror movie experiences was
together isn't actually not very
interesting I think they would expect
that
but I think our perspective on I don't
and I'm I don't know your perspective so
I'm interested to hear that my
perspective on that specifically Oh on
the past yeah and many other things
you've regaled me with your perspective
to know in on that first night of horror
Ness I've avoided ever talking about it
like talking about it tonight I'm gonna
open up some wounds oh yeah and yes
there's all wounds yeah so we we go deep
this is gonna become a psychological
thriller podcast mm-hm
we're gonna talk about that we're gonna
bear we're gonna bear our souls I had a
bad dream last night
I never have these type of dream dreams
snake never a bad dream snake dreams oh
I have a recurring snake dream I and I
don't have one and your wife does as
well she does yeah and you got it you
caught it it is like a virus I'm so
afraid of snakes in real life that they
need not make their way into my dreams
and I in you know on GMM I conquered my
fear by self talking which I did not
access that ability in the dream when I
was swimming in a tributary to like the
Amazon River in nothing but like trunks
yes swimming in tributaries is a thing
that happens in dreams and I was
swimming in it and there was like a
jungle around me and then I saw this
snake swimming right towards me it's a
sea snake Whitten it was like an
anaconda dude it was huge it was like a
20-foot snake with the head the size of
a basketball
mm-hmm and it swam up to me swam kind of
around me and I didn't panic and I kept
swimming and it was swimming around me
and then I finally got to like this
overlook even though I was still
swimming but I wasn't about to go off a
waterfall and I saw you down there
getting in a little kiddie boat I was in
the sea Canyon it was like a kiddie
kiddie ride with Locke and Lincoln you
were like get assuring them onto a kiddy
boat ride in the three of you under seat
Kitty boat ride no it was just down over
and over
cliff and you were down there and laws
of physics have been suspended in your
dream they were never there okay be
suspended right so I'm already tapping
into a few fears I might as well go all
the way what are you about to talk about
just let just lay bare my soul or at
least my you know talk about the big
decision of me I'm second-guessing it
guys I'm talking I'm talking about it
well you have to talk about it I know
now that I've said I'm gonna talk about
it cuz I know we know we have talked
about me talking about it but everyone's
going to talk about it
you don't right choice and because
everybody you know whenever you change
something about your appearance and your
me or you you know everybody's gonna
talk about it so you're gonna you just
need to go ahead and get ahead of it it
may be too late it's a little too late
to be ahead of it but you're kind of
just getting in sync with it I've got a
few gray hairs mm-hmm and by a few I
mean a lot I feel like I need to confess
that I've been hiding my gray hairs have
you been hiding them I've been coloring
the gray hairs what color they were gray
what color you been color purple you
haven't noticed the color of the rest of
my head oh yeah that makes sense
alright at least trying to approximate
it I didn't notice so I think you did a
great job I I don't know what when I
made the decision I think it was when we
were rapping buddy system I think I've
I've mentioned on a podcast that the the
people that you get closest to are the
the make up people and the hair people
cuz you see them at the beginning of
every day and the end of every day and
you have conversations with them and
they know they know your deepest fears
if we're getting lines cuz you're
cramming to study those right and you're
in a vulnerable position
but you know they're like you know you
got you get you got to do a better job
color in your hair like that you know
you just have conversations about this
I'm like yeah has you been doing it
personal I'd do it like got like a brush
what is it shoe polish well how does it
work I've been using just for men
it's because you're a man as you know I
am just a man nothing more and wait you
know because you don't want to go down
the aisle with all the women hair dye
you want to go on the man out with
duration is this just for men I want to
make sure this is just course not it's
so stupid it's marketing hold on this
would this would not work on a female's
hair right it's just for men just making
sure I guarantee you the stuff on the on
the the woman haircolor aisle which by
the way instead of just having like a
little swath of haircolor has an entire
aisle of the stuff is the same exact
stuff and probably cheaper or and more
expensive all types cuz nobody can
compete with just for men when just four
men came up with that they got the
corner on the man market right you can't
have like for everyone just for men one
and so that's where I went because men
aren't comfortable going down the the
women color aisle right I want to go
down the razor aisle and just pick it up
nobody's looking yeah that's just for me
I'll take it home it I mean it's
probably going back five years I may be
more than that I remember us I mean it
has to been more than that when I start
first started seeing some gray hairs
it's not because I'm old even though I
do blame it on my kids all the time
whenever they're like yeah you can I see
your gray hair well it's your fault it's
it's hereditary man it's not cuz I'm
gettin old it's cuz jeans my mom went
gray early but I look I'm hedging but
let me just say though so you're not I
mean you're not really going great I
just early I I mean you're 39 years old
I mean I'm a young guy yeah I know but
inside lots of people are in there in
their late 30s I think okay if you're
gonna go gray this is when it happened
but I've got some spring starting to it
just doesn't show up as much because my
hair is not as dark um so what I would
do was at first I would just I had some
like in my Park and I would just pluck
them out because they would be wiry yeah
they come back they come in a different
consistency and then it is cause like
right where your hair what part like all
the way back here I would notice some
some sprigs would become
they're a little pubis pubis but totally
white yeah like if your pubic region got
struck by lightning that's what it
looked like on top of my head and there
are benefits to when that happens my
uncle Roy oh yes for lightning on his
lightning rod I struck four like me and
then at a certain point I'm like whoa
right here where you would like hit a
soccer ball not the total front but just
behind that I saw a patch like over over
like my right frontal lobe like a little
white patch and I was like you know what
I'll just get a little bit of that beard
and mustache color because you you just
brush that on yeah so and then I would
like brush a little bit up there and a
little bit back here so I don't have to
plug that on the crown of my head and
then of course that's patch gets bigger
mm-hmm and girls it's like a virus I
remember one time I tried I was like
screw this I'm just gonna shampoo my
whole head with the hair dye and it was
when I went home for Christmas one time
I remember that and I was I was out
grilling and I cuz it says it only
sticks to the white hairs you look you
look like the dad from Adam's family
yeah Christmas and I remember I was I
was grilling I was grilling with my dad
who I was living out here so I don't see
him as often and I remember when I was
grilling I'm a sudden I noticed he was
looking at me instead of the grill and
he was like you got your hair he said
that and I was like yeah I tried well
it's just a spot here and there but I
tried the old thing and it didn't he
went black I was like I am NOT gonna do
that again so then over time over years
out but just you know like this I
noticed I was using more and more of the
just for men but can I out of the lube
let me interject because and you start
to go ahead I think that not to speak
for you but to speak for you because I'm
also speaking for myself yeah I think
that the tendency to want to to dye the
hair I think was rooted in we've always
had this feeling that people perceived
us to be younger than we actually are
because
most people do if you just stumble on
one of our videos you don't think well I
don't know I'm starting to I'm starting
to look older faster I think we're
working too hard
but rewind just a couple years you
wouldn't think that guy's about to turn
40 I don't think right and so and we
felt like in order to succeed on YouTube
we couldn't be seen as like old old guys
and so it was just like everybody does
it people dye their hair sure so it's
like yeah I don't want it I don't want
him to think I'm old I don't want to
become irrelevant I literally thought
out loud you can shout to myself George
Clooney did it George Clooney did what
dyed his hair like that was a rationale
for me to film along did he do it he
does it on and off you know he I mean
four years before that movie in Hawaii
he would do it all the time he would he
would he was gray on ER dude he was
salt-and-pepper on ER right but he
wasn't doing it to hide it he was no her
part he was he was doing it well no he
would do it in real life as like this is
who this is my normal look but he wasn't
trying to not let anyone know that he
wouldn't know because he was on ER as a
right I don't even know if I'm right but
i use it as a rationalization don't
think it's true but i don't think he
ever does is because the flip side of
being on youtube is that there's a level
of expected authenticity that you don't
is that's not required of just an actor
mm-hmm so i always felt a little bad
about it or I mean self-conscious about
it at least and I think you all were to
the day well it's not like we didn't
talk about it maybe thank you well like
I was keeping it from you or anything it
what you didn't think you dreaded the
day that you'd have to let it go and
make the switch right and if you knew
that still in the public eye and all of
a sudden I become Anderson Cooper I got
some splaining to do right my Uncle Dan
had a had a big red beard and reddish
hair and he was a school principal for
years and then one day he comes over to
Nana Papa's house his in-laws to eat
dinner like we did every month and he
had gotten a promotion to be like this
soup
Intendant of the public schools in the
county of Harnett and and all of a
sudden he was full gray it was like a
different man was eating dinner with us
and I was like that's shocking I
wouldn't want to do that to anybody
yeah well peace you've avoided that
right but yeah but me so I think that's
what went into making the decision now
was you know what I think I just got a I
don't I feel like I'm covering something
up emotionally or in some way besides
obviously physically and didn't make me
feel comfortable you know I also feel
free just just I felt safe enough with
like the mythical beast to be to be gray
if I have gray hairs yes but in my own
brain I had to let my had to let I've
gave him give myself permission because
we were all so sensitive about we would
also avoid talking about how old we were
right you know up to probably like five
years ago right now it's just you know
but when this podcast comes out I will
be 40 years old that's right and we
everyone knows that now and I'm not
worried about it and there is something
freeing about that and I decided when
the makeup people with buddy system
would like brush the white hairs that I
didn't die with like something in
between takes to like cover it up like
enough of this this is for the birds and
like trying to color my own hair over
the weekend or you don't know how many
fights me and Christy got in with her
trying to cut color this part in the
back she wouldn't do it right yeah in my
opinion she wasn't doing it right but in
her opinion she didn't have to do it at
all so poor woman gosh so there were so
many factors that just pushed me over
the edge but the main one is just to be
me you know if I want to tell people to
be themselves and to be confident and
who they are why need to do that you
know yeah but I actually think that
there
I think that ultimately you will only
experience a positive benefit that's
redundant
you will only experience benefit from
this I don't think there's any negative
that can come from this I think if
anything there'll be some parent who's
watching good mythical morning over
their child's head shoulder and they'll
see you in a minute he's old he must be
about my age maybe I'll start watching
maybe this is for me or they'll look
over their kids shoulder and be like why
are you watching that old man this is
creepy
this is creepy for everybody I think
that I might I might lose some some fans
who psychologically think it's creepy to
watch a an old guy but you'll gain some
but everyone you don't you'll gain too I
hope to gain so many more who are fan of
salt-and-pepper hair and I don't know
it's just in here it's not everywhere
well it's kind of it we're all on the
sides I mean it will and it eventually
will be everywhere yeah I guess I feel
better
yeah you should no I feel fine I feel
good about the about the decision and
you know what mythical beast you will
feel better when you cuddle up in a good
mythical hoodie do I have one to show
I've got one you have the boil for
safety mug over there and then cuddle up
with a boil for safety mug you know what
this is it's just made of metal man you
can sit there and take it on your
camping trip take your hoodie in you and
your tin cup and cuddle up next to the
fire it's getting cold out there some
places in the world it's already bit
walk world yeah definitely but some
places in the u.s. it's already cold I
feel sorry for you guys in California we
wear hoodies just as a fashion statement
we never ever actually need them it's
just I mean maybe there's like three
days a year where you actually need a
hood I don't I don't ant I sell it I'm
just saying you want a hoodie but you
wasn't the best hoodie
feel good the backs got a dykon logo on
it - man
dadgum dead limb logo on the back it's
the same logo as the front but it's
bigger should be backwards on the back
like you're seeing the reverse image
support entertainment and show your
mythical beasts leanness go to mythical
dot store okay
so we're gonna talk about our experience
with horror movies and I do believe that
I mean I think I saw horror movies
before the one that we're gonna talk
about first
mm-hm we can just start with our common
experience because I believe that was
definitely your first or movie and it
was a it was a big one to start with oh
my goodness well this is what I remember
do you know what grade it was fourth
grade uh third grade
it was sixth grade sixth grade because I
remember another monumental event that
happened that night that I will talk
about in another podcast so sixth grade
and that's how I mark that year sixth
grade we had a group sleepover at Adam
Nicholson's house yep I never had a
sleepover at Adam Nicholson's house and
so it was I guess it was his birthday I
was like this this is going all night
man I don't know whose idea was to put
on the Texas Chainsaw Massacre all I
remember is but I was here he was
talking about it and I was just so
excited to watch it because unlike a did
he go to like coats party beverage and
like tanning salon and and rent the VHS
he must have I mean his older brother
who worked at Hooters probably did Larry
Larry yeah yeah hooter frying he
probably also I mean even fry the
hooters you fried the willies
he also probably owned it Larry's the
kind of guy that would have owned Texas
Chainsaw Massacre
Larry was cool but the the parents knew
that we it wasn't not it was not a we
weren't sneaking around the parents knew
that we were watching it and I was super
excited because I'd already kind of been
enjoying horror movies and the idea of
enjoying the horror movie in a group of
my friends was especially exciting to me
I think that horror movies even though
they're like rated R are designed for
sixth graders to watch because it can
just scare the living crap out of you
and change your entire life like I said
I was just I didn't I never heard of it
before I never watched a horror movie
before and the moment he said we were
gonna watch it I was like freaking out
in my brain but I wasn't gonna tell
anybody because that wasn't cool I mean
I definitely thought about bailing on
the whole sleepover entirely I'm sure of
it
well but I don't know you were already
anxious just about being at a sleepover
yeah yeah for a reason that I didn't
know at the time I did not know that you
were so anxious about it I was like
Shirley link is having just as good of a
time as I am at this strangers house not
the stranger assessment at this friend
that we don't know that Wales house I
never spent the night over there but I
felt comfortable doing it in a group so
he brought out Chainsaw Massacre also
that night we stuck somebody's hand in
warm water and trying to get him to pee
themselves yeah after we went to sleep
who was that who would that have been I
don't know I doing work I do remember
hey Ryan
but didn't work I don't remember it um
for those of you don't know I'm gonna
read the synopsis of Texas Chainsaw
Massacre made in 1974 released in 1974
actually shot in 73 outside of Austin
Texas
when Sally hears that her grandfather's
grave may have been vandalized
she and her paraplegic brother Franklin
set out with their friends to
investigate after a detour to their
family's old farmhouse oh they discover
a group of crazed murderous outcasts
living next door
leave it was an incestuous family of
freaks the way I would put it as the
group has attacked one by one by the
chainsaw wielding Leatherface who wears
a mask of human skin the survivors must
do everything they can to escape this
thing was made for a hundred and forty
thousand dollars I mean you can kind of
tell when you watch it it's pretty clear
that it was a low-budget film yeah made
over 30 million in the box office
gracious that's a great return on your
investment but I just remember watching
it that night and then well do you
remember what do you remember about that
movie like does anything specifically
stand out because there's one scene that
really stands out for me with the
meathook no I just kind of have a vague
memory of a bit of Leatherface and a
chainsaw I distinctly remember I mean to
me it was like yeah it was like a like a
refrigerated butcher room but he like
takes this girl and then he there's like
a meat hook and he hangs her on the meat
hook like through her back she's hang in
there man it was so grotesque and that
family acted so weird and the fact that
it was shot in 1974 it just looked so
disturbing and it was so hackish Lee
done like it all played into like being
horrifying I mean there was a it was the
guy who played the granddad and he had
like this I watched this clip so I only
remember this part from rewatching it a
second ago because I was I wanted to
verify the meathook which I did and I
shouldn't have verified meathook but do
you remember there was like there was
like a granddad at the milliner table
old and he had like really old man
makeup and like a like a latex skin on
and then they took the girl and they cut
her finger and then they mate and then
the granddad was sucking on that on her
finger it's just demented story man
cinema now see you're saying this
demented and horrifying as if I didn't
I mention the guy with this human skin
masa you did chainsaw synopsis you're
saying all this as this is a as it's
I cannot speak to you I've been talking
too much today it doesn't matter this as
if it's a bad thing you say oh it's so
horrifying that's what makes it such a
great thing is there really nothing at
all about the experience of just being
just totally scared to the your core but
knowing that you're not really in any
danger there's is there not anything
exhilarating about that I didn't know
that I wasn't in danger it's like but
something there was no logic component
to this I mean it was like in the dream
when the snake swam up to me in the
tributary there was a snake and I was
swimming I mean I experienced that as a
sixth grader in in in the similar way
cuz you remember what happened afterward
we went outside yeah when the movies
over then someone had the bright idea to
be like let's go outside in his backyard
backed up to a huge field and then we
everyone just started walking into the
field in the pitch-black at night and it
was like a cornfield or like and we're
walking into it and then all of a sudden
once she walk into the field you can't
see your friends anymore
yeah so I'm alone in a field in a place
I've never been and I can hear rustling
presumably of you people former friends
of mine walking in there and it was I
mean I was waiting for Leatherface to
jump out at any moment
dizzy this is you know it was
unfortunate it's just interesting
because sometimes there are these life
events that really highlight very stark
differences we're very similar in a lot
of ways very different in a lot of ways
so when a group of kids it was probably
your idea when a group of kids goes into
a dark corn field the only thing I'm
thinking is how do I scare someone and
you're thinking you're here think I'm
thinking am I gonna die right and I'm
like you become the victim and I think
Leatherface yeah that's you become the
girl in the meathook and I become
Leatherface six your sixth grade
Leatherface I mean there's I love
scaring people you're like doing it I
should have brought my chainsaw like we
would go we would go camping yes across
the across the river yeah we would all
be walking and then sometimes I would we
would be walking through the woods I
have a sudden I turn around gonna be
gone but where's red and I would
literally devote like an hour of my time
I would let you guys get completely
ahead of me and then I would walk
through the woods and I would get like
100 yards from the campsite it's totally
dark and I would very very slowly and
acting I would get up next to the to the
campsite I can hear you guys and you
would all be like he's gonna come scare
us he's gonna scare us at any moment but
I would way he wait wait close and I
would wait for you to get right to that
moment where you would let your guard
down and I would just come out there and
scream well they can't I were love doing
I remember this one time because the
campsite was on the other side of the
river and then again another tributary
came off of the river and formed our
campsite on an island yeah and I
remember we set up camping and you went
to take a leak and never came back
didn't come back it was pitch dark occur
outside of the camp fire zone and then
after a while I go to take a leak and I
go next to the tributary and I swear for
the past thirty minutes you had been
submerged in the waters in the river
you were a guy in the river and just
kept my eyes above the water and waited
for somebody come take away like like
predator right like Arnold
Schwarzenegger later for that kind of
thing I'd do it to my kids too but you
know I did it I did pee on you my dad
did it to me I remember really vividly
coming back over walking back home from
Ben Greenwoods house and my mom had
called me and said you need to come home
uh-huh it was like it was late or
whatever and so my dad knew that I was
walking from Keith Hills back to our
house it's like a mile walk like across
a couple of cornfields and the same
cornfield
yeah same core that but yeah Adams house
back I'm like walking I come out of the
cornfield and then I'm walking paths
like on the grass field in front of my
house and I get right up to the road and
all of a sudden the bush starts shaking
and then all of a sudden there's a dog
going and then I realize this is my dad
and I feel like I'm on the ground you
laid on the ground was so scared then he
just laughs and you got a thrill out of
that or or you wanted to be your dad
what you like one day I'm gonna be the
scare I decided I'm gonna have the pal I
have a very similar personality makeup
it's like I did I wasn't scarred by it
was just like hey what do we win and I
was like man you got me you know and
then then I just you know I just I
carried on the cycle but it's not that
you experience joy and being scared it's
that I but I do I do i do that's what so
that's where I want to go with this
because you like riding a roller coaster
right yeah and to me that the joy of
riding a roller coaster as long as I'm
not getting sick is the feeling of being
in danger with not really being in
danger now of course that's not the part
I like about it now of course there is I
like the fun part yeah but what makes it
fun it's the thrill and what makes it a
thrill the the physical sensation I mean
I could just pick you up and throw you
around and that wouldn't be fun well it
might be odd I don't think it would be I
don't think he would be the same thing
to me
so you're saying is it the adrenaline so
she ated with a simulated near-death
experience on a roller coaster where I
can suspend my my fear of actual death
and I'm scarier it is the the more the
sensation right so okay so when we went
to Six Flags with the team and we got on
that what was the one where were you
were flying what was that called where
was that thing called the one at Six
Flags that's like insane
sponsored by it done by the by the chips
I don't know what it's called anyway
there's one where you basically are
strapped in and you're flying and the
whole time I was strapped in I was
thinking
if this thing yeah we went we were we
talked about this right and so but
that's what made it great is that I
actually thought man I am I could
actually be in danger but then when you
get through it and you're done you're
like that was the best one that's the
one I would remember that's the that was
the best experience I had at Six Flags
was the time I thought I was gonna die
and then I didn't so a horror movie is
is your mom also thing also train you to
like that experience in the form of
horror movies too because she would
she'd force-feed you horror movies as a
baby I don't think that my mom really
understood like my mom thought that her
presence with you made whatever he were
watching okay it was like parental
guidance as long as I guide him through
this it'll be okay
well R stands for restrict now but she
has denied this please drink without mom
being because I've talked about how
either on the podcast or good mythical
morning I don't know watching Hellraiser
how she got me to watch Hellraiser or
she let me watch Hellraiser with her and
when I was very young and she denied
this and she says I wouldn't have done
that and I was like well how what do I
remember it and how do I remember we're
sitting there next to you watching so
but she loves horror movies my mom will
go see horror movies of ourself like she
called me last year and she was like I
just went to see insidious four or
whatever what she wanted was by myself
and I was the only one in the theater
what and she loved it she loves me she
loves every minute of it so there's
something in our blood that makes us
want to experience these things but but
and I've made kind of a feels wrong the
funny thing is is I don't have a lot of
people in my life to enjoy horror movies
with Jesse doesn't like to watch him you
don't really like to watch him we will
talk in a second about some of the ones
up we have enjoyed together or we both
have enjoyed recently but one of my
favorite horror movie stories is I
learned that my father-in-law oh well
you this movie you made me watch it with
you in the theater and then you watched
it again with him oh the ring yes okay I
saw the ring in the theater in
Greensboro in Greensboro
yeah okay after Christmas because you
were like man we got we got some time
we're on the road let's stop at a
theater and watch the ring and I'm like
no
we'll watch something else and we get
there and there's nothing else within a
hour-and-a-half timeframe so then you
forced me to watch the ring and how do
you remember that don't don't pull up
your mom on me I remember it because it
scared the daylights out of how do you
remember that not how I remember that
with my brain I don't - tell me about
your experience how do you recall that
what was it like to watch the movie how
do you go about removing like tell me
about the experience Oh what do you mean
man no I was just making my brain I
ain't scared it scared me it was very
you enjoy any of it it was all bad yeah
I I can read the synopsis and then I'll
let you tell the story about I think
most people know that synopsis do the
ring but feel free to read it it sounds
like just another urban legend a
videotape filled with nightmarish images
leads to a phone call for telling the
viewers death in exactly seven days why
couldn't it be in the video why you got
to get a phone call anyway newspaper
reporter Rachel Keller played by Naomi
Watts his skeptical of the story until
four teenagers all died mysteriously
exactly one week after watching just
such a tape allowing her investigative
curiosity to get the better of her
Rachel tracks down the video and watches
it now she has just seven days to you to
unravel the mystery even reading that
scared me so we washed it together I
really enjoyed it I like watch I do not
watch horror movies by myself I've I've
almost done it a couple of times but I'm
not like my mom I don't want to do that
because I the thing I enjoy is being
with someone who's also getting scared
that's why my birthday parties usually
consist of watching a horror movie
together with a bunch of adults mm-hmm
because I like to see especially people
who don't like to watch horror movies
get scared but I found that my
father-in-law
also like to watch horror movies and so
I know this is years ago we just gotten
married to Jesse so this is what came
out in 2002 so it's probably 2003 yeah
it was like right when it came out on
video mm-hmm and she's like he's like
let's watch a horror movie together I'm
gonna go get the ring I'm gonna go yell
was when you went to rent movies and he
comes back with it and okay we're gonna
watch this thing together and we're in
the living room together and then Jesse
and her mom are on the other side of the
house like on the Sun porch they called
it so like basically outside of the
house and you should explain what
happens in the movie yeah so well of
course Stella in the movie won something
well yeah the way that she kills you she
comes and you're watching the tape and
then she comes out of the television and
kills you yeah and so and the first
scene is probably the scariest one the
first murder in the mood in the movie in
the original ring is incredibly scary so
sitting there watching it we got all the
lights off and got the volume cranked up
real high and there's this moment when
it's zooming in on the television and I
know what's about it happened because
I've seen the movie I know she's about
to come out of there and as soon as hurt
that black hair greasy black hair is
like right there at the screen at the
peak of the music and the build-up and
everything all of a sudden the TV the
speaker everything the whole
entertainment center just goes dude and
just cuts off and then we both ran ran
to the Sun porch she ran to your mom we
ran to you ladies
we just ran in there it was like we did
like run all the way across the house
and then we ran in there and they're
like what
with your father-in-law why you guys
running in here we're like the horror
movie just did something in real life
oh my goodness but then you looked over
and your dad was holding the plug no
laughing my father no barking like
whatever I think that's crazy I think
actually what timing of it my prey
scientific my completely rational
explanation of this is that we had it
turned up so loud and the bass was so it
was the music was peaking at that point
then something happened it overpowered
the system and then it went out or maybe
the ring is real and if we hadn't run
out of the room to the sunporch we would
be dead
wasn't there a viral video of people you
know there was like a bunch of
televisions and like a Best Buy or
something and then a ring girl crawls
out of a television yeah that was for
like the most recent ring you know
campaign that's it if you've got a
horror movie these days you got to have
some viral campaign like that where
somebody gets you know thrown up against
the wall by some witch in a coffee shop
that kind of thing you got to have that
if you want anybody watch your movie
it's a remake of a Japanese horror
classic but so so what I have done for a
number of my birthday's is I've invited
since we moved out here I've invited a
lot of people over to watch a horror
movie with me so and and and just to
bring you up to speed on on my horror
movie watching life you took me to see
the ring well after the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre I did not watch another horror
movie I didn't even watch gremlins I
don't believe that's technically a
horror movie but I wouldn't watch it
I would not watch anything that could
remotely be scary after that movie
probably until you see the ring as a
married adult man with a few gray hairs
just a few but then so this is right
three years ago maybe four years ago
because we were we're definitely the old
in the
previous studio hmm and I was like
downstairs did not have any windows I'm
gonna have a birthday party I'm gonna
invite all my friends over and we're
gonna watch the conjuring together and
it's great because your birthday is in
October so it's like everybody's in the
the Halloween mood festivity right and
nobody would conjuring every everybody
was kind of in the same place they were
like not really fans of horror movies
but one person in particular hated
horror movies more than you yeah that
was Tony yeah he said I don't want to be
here but I know this is you you know
we're friends it's your birthday not to
name drop but for context we're talking
about Tony Hale yeah so now it's funnier
because you can you can imagine what I
like to watch him watching a horror
Buster from Arrested Development or I
mean even more famously now whatever he
is on veep I can't remember his name
right now Gary Gary but yeah just
imagine him I mean he was like I'm only
here because we're friends and I want to
support you as a friend but and then he
proceeded to put on headphones while we
watched the movie he put in earbuds and
listen to music while we watched the
movie like I think the way you put it
was like really nice music yeah
like friendly music and he also left a
couple of times yeah so he wouldn't he
wouldn't watch the movie but he wanted
to be supportive so he listened to the
nice music and he didn't and he looked
at us and I gotta say that is very kind
of him I really appreciate the support
but I would have enjoyed it more if he
had had just committed fully to the
experience because that's the thing
that's so exhilarating to me for you to
be entertained at his expense well I
like everybody to be in this this I love
to watch it in a group because
everybody's grabbing on to each other
and it's just like you're you're just
experiencing this as it
hmmm it's like you're like it's as close
as you can get to being like one of
those pods that's gonna roam around
during the Apocalypse
you know what I'm saying like I'd like
though if we can get through this week
together right we can we can we'll be
safe safety and do anything we can do
anything we can get to this movie and
the conjuring was especially scary shall
I read them read the synopsis link in
1970 paranormal investigators in
demonologist Lorraine and Edie Warren
are summoned to the home of Carolyn and
Roger Perron the parents and their five
daughters have recently moved into a
secluded farmhouse there's that
farmhouse again where a supernatural
presence has made itself known though
the manifestations are relatively benign
at first events soon escalate in
horrifying fashion especially after the
Warren's discovered the houses McCobb
history and now these dean OPS's are not
very great for horror movies because
they can't give anything away right yeah
but you can keep reading them yeah the
thing of the thing about any any sort of
demon related horror movie is there's
this there's always been this thing in
the back of my mind that I'm like it's
do it's different than just a very crazy
dude but it's grotesque monster that
feels like very removed from the human
experience but then when all of a sudden
there's like a demon in the house you're
like you could be in your house right
now I don't know what I actually think
about this believe it or not but it
could be true I don't know and then you
and then you you really start getting
scared and then and if it is true and
you don't believe in it you're not
believing and it doesn't matter
and yeah right and give me their day and
then when you get home he can be there
you're thinking yeah oh man you know
that the Swamp Thing Swamp Thing is not
gonna be in your house yeah cuz you're
not your house is not in a swamp but
maybe your house is haunted maybe
there's a demon under the bed right earn
your dog or something like that well I
prefer to think that he's hiding behind
the trash cans which is why I always run
back
the house after throwing the trash away
and then the following year I got
everyone to watch the babadook
I'm giving up on the synopsis yeah that
one was no this is the one where the kid
basement the kid was spooked out about
this babadook haunting him and the mom
starts talking to it read the synopsis
dude Emilia who lost her husband in a
car crash on the way to give birth to
Samuel Oh only first of all kids their
only child
oh you can't you you like come from a
horror movie situation as an only child
yeah you know like you could have been
like the little boy in a horror movie
that's the thing maybe you are mm-hmm
struggles to cope with her fate as a
single mom this is like sue yeah Sam
Link's constant fear of monsters and
violent reaction to overcome the fear
doesn't help Sue's calls either which
makes her friends become distant when
things cannot get any worse they freed a
strange book in their house about the
babadook monster that hides in the dark
areas of their house hey honey
you're troubled I've got an idea let me
read you a story about the babadook what
kind of mom even sue seems to feel the
effect of babadook and desperately tries
in vain to destroy the book the
nightmarish experience is the to
encounter from the form the rest of the
story now but she would talk to it in
order to try to get it to go away right
and I think it firt that at first she
was doing that to calm the kid but then
it was it was actually that's another
great device in a horror movie is a
child yeah children now first of all
those scariest I think I've said this
before but the scariest possible thing
in a horror movie is like a like a
little girl that has somehow been
corrupted by evil because you've got the
most innocent thing you can possibly
think of that in the irony of it so like
poltergeist or whatever that those
movies are or even like The Exorcist
where you've got
like a young girl getting possessed by a
demon like that the juxtaposition there
is just so strong and so but the
babadook was really scary but it didn't
get me as much as the conjuring it
wasn't as pure of an experience Tony
didn't come to that part no he didn't
you know he's too scared he didn't music
so it's interesting because this whole
that was at your house and there were
windows - that's true this whole come on
some people were in the other room like
and we're talking away it's hard to be
isolated in a house yeah because it's so
to open but this concept of watching
horror movies for it for entertainment
like in a group has passed on to our
kids
yes we're interestingly so and I my son
get that directly from me
I bet Locke did it but - my family but
Lincoln is now in on it and he's not
like I remember Lincoln like would watch
like think of something that's not
actually scary that like gremlins but
not even gremlins he would like watch
like Land Before Time
Odin dinosaurs can step on you exactly
and then he would like have to come
upstairs yeah and then sleep with you
guys yeah but now Locke's got him
watching they watch freakin Annabelle
together yeah it's like a status symbol
to be able to brag to your friends and
like I watched that's the baby doll I
think you're seeing it wrong though you
you think I think they think he thought
it was cool you think kids are watching
it because they're trying to prove
something you don't think that the idea
of just this I think Locke watches it
for the same reason that I do to get
really really scared we went to see it
Lincoln watched it because Locke was
into it well before I tell the it story
because I want to talk about the two
horror movies of 2017 that I think are
just like probably my two favorite
movies of 2017 or both horror movies but
mm-hmm
the other night well this has been this
has been a few weeks we were at your
house and Locke was like dad Lincoln and
I are gonna watch Annabelle and so they
go back to Lincoln's room they put the
movie on and then Lily while they're
watching the movie she goes and gets a
bunch of her
all's that she used to play with and she
sits them in the hallway yeah so the
first thing they're gonna see when they
come out after the movie is a bunch of
dolls staring right out that way like
American Girl dolls like those that like
big ones with the big big open eyes yes
American Girl dolls yeah so and they got
him out of the garage I'm like why why
are we keeping these Oh for Asians okay
so what they did they opened the door
and they both kicked the dolls they was
like involved freaked out react attacked
the dolls yeah and and which I love that
that's what I live for stuff like yeah
Lily it's like it's like you hiding in
the in the river water up to your eyes
like an alligator that's what she was
doing I think part of it has to do with
the fact that we just don't I think
humans are you know we're basically it's
in our DNA to be scared and to escape to
escape thing it's a safety mechanism
when in doubt over and over a great of
it you know selectively we've still got
this Stone Age hardware right and we've
got the modern day software but the
hardware our DNA is basically designed
so that we will experience this
incredible stress and then we will move
away from it and they'll be this like
feeling of euphoria when we get away
from that thing right yes that was
reinforced over millions of years but we
don't live and that's one of the reasons
we have all these health problems is
because we live we have this very
constant low-grade stress that causes a
cortisol release which is very unhealthy
to have this like constant release as
opposed to like a big flurry of it and
then it's and then it's over easily so
you you think that your mom taught you
from an early age to flush the system I
don't know if it's because I'm already
I'm also living in the stressed-out
modern-day world with this unhealthy
level of like low-grade stress I'm just
saying that I think one of the reasons
that you feel good after you watch
something that's really scary and then
you're and then it's over is like it's
for me it is that flush but there is
also the bonding that's why I like to
watch it with somebody so like if I run
from a bear and get
away from beer it's pretty exhilarating
but if we run from a bear in both get
away we're like we're like you know we'd
reinforce something between the two of
us or if we run from a bear but I run
faster from the bear right then the bear
gets you and I get away so that's even
better even better but that's what makes
horror movie so amazing because nobody
actually is killed by the movie right
you get out and so oh get out let's talk
about get out my favorite movie of the
year
yep I just want to give a shout-out to
cabin in the woods but I'm we're not
gonna talk about that okay because
that's that was another horror movie
that you loved because it wasn't it was
well yeah you don't want to do any
spoilers you've seen it all right you
usually see if you're gonna if you love
horror movies you should see it and if
you don't love horror movies like me
you should see it right it's a perfect
horror movie for people who don't love
horror movies but get out which we did
not see together we saw separately right
cuz I saw it right yeah but we saw it
like the same weekend and it's just like
a perfect movie man well everything it's
so rare that people rave and rave about
a movie and then you you haven't watched
the any like man it's - bill - no way
yeah I can't live up kinda height and
then it does I didn't know any of the
details and if you don't I don't I don't
think I want to tell you but um but I
encouraged you to see it if you've
avoided horror movies definitely cabin
in the woods definitely probably get out
before cabin in the world yeah yeah yeah
cuz get out is actually not as right I
don't think it's as scary as cabin in
the woods and all it's not a cabin the
woods is like a trophy movie that's like
making fun is a parody of horror movies
yeah with a twist but this is more of a
thriller like I mean I didn't watch
those either like hand that rocks the
cradle' any of that stuff but it's a
little different than a horror movie
like a psychological thriller yeah so
and that's what get out is and it also
has this incredible social message which
is like you know and it's in did think
that it was pretty is so amazing about
it you got a guy Jordan Peele who you
know is one half of a comedy duo we can
relate to that who all of a sudden just
busts out this perfect movie that makes
100 million dollars that's crazy that's
a feat in and of itself and he also has
said that he's got like a handful more
of these type of movies I loved that he
did that but he got address something
important in a really creative way yeah
I would say he's a he is a creative hero
of mine oh definitely along with Beck
Beck Beck is a musical creative hero of
mine the way he can shape-shift and I
just I really have this on my creative
heart and I want to do it hmm
Becca yeah I'm a fan but I have one more
but I can't remember right now who it is
keeping a running list of Moby no
creative heroes of mine but I saw Moby
and uh saw Moby at kitchen mouse felt a
backup mobis head you could switch any
of those three words around and I'd
still believe it I saw a mouse at the
kitchen Moby might say I don't know what
you're talking about so it but then I
presume that you're moving on to it oh
gosh yes because what you were talking
about with the kids was they've been
badgering us to see it and I'm like now
I remember when I was 10 years old and
it came out on television as a
miniseries as a network television and
yeah and I couldn't do anything because
everybody about Network tell everybody
at school was talking about it so I did
watch a lot of that but it had that
creepy clown and it scared the crap out
of me and I don't recall watching all of
it but I watch portions of it just to be
in the know I watched that with my
brother
I remember watching that miniseries but
this it first of all guys come on let's
be real this the it from this year is so
much better than the original let's just
let's just be honest is that a is that a
question you know people there are
people who no matter how things are done
they always say those as good as the
original he's not as good of a clown is
the first guy not as scary it's not as
creepy this you're wrong okay I know
that this is seems like a subjective
thing but you are objectively wrong if
you think the original it is better
the current hit on every level you are
wrong you have a in you have an
incorrect perception of the world and
those two movies okay let's so now that
that's out of the way this it ain't and
now they're like I'm glad you pointed
that out
I am totally swayed by your cogent
argument it was very gracious - it's
soso won the hearts and minds of every
hey I'm not about winning hearts and
minds I'm just about stating facts it's
now that I've settled it so it is so
good now there's a lot of people and I
well let me say it is so good I so loved
it - except for that clown part you know
you loved every minute of it oh man man
I'm not proud of the fact that I took my
kids to see it not lando of course but I
mean Lincoln and once once you see all
the other ones like Lincoln has and he's
not coming up to my bedroom at night
scared then I'm like alright fine we'll
go see it if I get some cool points out
of it I'm kind of curious so yeah I'm
not proud nor not proud that I took them
to see it yeah and you took lot you in
La Quinta see all right so a lot was
playing basketball at the Y and then I
picked him up and I didn't tell him I
picked him up and I was like you guys we
got to go home and get ready cuz in one
hour we're gonna be watching it and his
face just lit up
which as a dad I just love being able to
do something like that with him and then
during the movie we were grabbing each
other in screaming the entire we were
running from the bear and repeatedly
getting away together and we bonded
because of that absolutely and he's
going back to see it again that's
interesting because I reserved seats for
me Lillian Lincoln and then a friend of
theirs and their friend's mom but the
seats couldn't all be together so me and
the friend's mom sat together yeah and
yeah I did so yeah there wasn't as much
like grabbing each other and camaraderie
with like my kids friend's mom that I
kind of know right well I was also I was
actually kind of disappointed
pointed because not in the movie but in
the people watching the movie because
the movie was so good it was scary now
first of all there are people who don't
think the clown is scary and I think
that that's fine if you're not scared of
something you can't help it people just
think it was to see was like cartoony or
something I don't know if you're if you
don't find the clowns find the clowns
scary then the whole thing is ruined for
you and I know there's some people at
the office who didn't find him scary so
you can't argue with that
I found it incredibly scary I kind of
give myself over to movies when I watch
him but after the first scene I think
they did a bang-up job of establishing
how afraid you should be of this glass
it was a great first right off the bat
and also it was surprising I was like
woah incredibly funny
those kids first of all those kids are
incredible actors and it was just
crafted so I mean like cinematically
like even in that shot like there's that
overhead shot where it's raining in the
aftermath of what happened and there's
you know it's like the waters draining
away all the visual choices but the kids
on the couch I've never seen a mostly
kids name what's the kid's name from
stranger things to the main dude from it
and stranger things kid from stranger
things I think is what he's properly
called yeah Finn okay so he was great
exactly one of the things about that kid
is that in a way that hasn't it hasn't
happened since the 80s that you kind of
saw kids kind of grow up and star in
movies that adults liked yeah so very
nostalgic the 90s the 90s kind of
ushered in this time and definitely most
of the 2000s have been where kids are in
movies that are mostly for kids and then
occasionally people you know stars star
kids adults will tolerate the movies but
back in the 80s you had like kids that
were in family movies that became stars
and they kind of grew up and they grew
good actors never respected like I can
totally see that kid becoming being
somebody that we know for our entire
lives as an actor you know that just
doesn't happen a lot but he's incredible
he's incredible and stranger things he's
incredible and it yeah all the kids are
it that's the cool thing is that it's a
book from the 80s set
it was written then right I mean it I
mean it certainly came out as a
miniseries in the 80s then he I think he
I think he wrote it in the mid eighties
you know and obviously this is the
stranger things phenomenon that's
happening I'm not saying anything you
haven't heard here but an obviously
stranger things was inspired by it which
gave it permission to then Berrian
spired by stranger things but they
didn't have to make the choice to set it
back in the eighties necessarily I guess
that was a story so they kind of had to
do that but this style of it but then
adding on top of it the nostalgia factor
that you're talking about of kids stars
in movies for adults and kids was was
like that last piece that brought it all
together it's like it's in the 80s it in
its shot like that like a movie from the
80s yeah but done in like the highest
production value of now but also that
whole phenomenon is very nostalgic yeah
and then just visually there's so many
memorable and horrifying scenes and it
keeps coming at you it's like um it's
unrelenting you know and how many times
it just keeps coming back I'm tempted to
say that I like horror movies I mean I'm
gushing about this movie
maybe I finally switched over you like
good horror movies which I agree there's
not a lot of them you know most horror
movies are bad but this year has been
but it had it but it had other things it
had humor and it had well a lot of harm
the best horror movies have are funny as
well I mean get out was hilarious
yeah yeah and even some of the best ones
from from back in the day like night
melt Nightmare on Elm Street or Friday
the 13th like what they were funny cuz
well of course I never saw Freddy
Krueger was funny he was legit funny
like he had like one liner just one
liners yeah oh really
yeah he was funny you can watch those
now and you won't be you really won't be
scared but but talk about laughs the
remake I have another point to make it
verse it then versus it now it's the
same people make the argument that you
know if
if the NBA players from the 80s played
the NBA players from today they would
totally beat the NBA NBA players for
today they were just it was so much more
of a pure game and they were they were
tougher physically you were also wrong
you were objectively wrong if the NBA
championship team if the if the Golden
State Warriors were to play the 1993 or
95 Chicago Bulls they would decimate
them hobo Horace Grant they you don't
you don't you got to understand how much
the game has changed in in 20 30 years
it's changed so much like they move
faster it's you can definitively prove
this somebody needs to just
scientifically break it down so their
argument would just be over forever I'm
just telling you I know that they were
great they proved it in the Olympics
every game exactly exactly so there's a
definitive measure of athleticism and
what happens with World Records they get
broken every year they're at the
Olympics for these definitive things
like sprinting and jumping and
weightlifting typically there are
records that are set why is basketball
any different the game is evolving kids
my kid is playing basketball right now
and they are settled in Jordan they are
so much better than I was at that age
and I realized we're in you know we're
in Southern California but North
Carolina has a pretty good basketball
state but like the skill level of all
these kids like the mean skill level is
so much higher than what we had there's
just no cut there's no contest and all
the filmmaking to take it back to
filmmaking we've gotten so much better
the technology has gotten so much better
and the sound and all these things have
gotten so much better and not to mention
the it would not even be is not an
argument because the original it was a
network television miniseries that
couldn't had so many lines that they
couldn't cross so many things that they
couldn't show and couldn't say and then
you and you don't have those
restrictions with the the modern-day
versions there's no contest while we
were talking about this
I think the exception is there will
never be another Texas Chainsaw Massacre
except for the fact that they've made
like countless sequels am I wrong in
thinking it
Matthew McConaughey was in a Texas
Chainsaw Massacre sequel
I think you're wrong about George
Clooney dyeing his hair ever and I think
you're wrong dude George Clooney dyes
his hair for roles yeah but then for
roles only but like on in like not as on
the front of a magazine no no no okay
say that on my craft Matthew McConaughey
was in Texas Chainsaw Massacre the next
what no that was Star Trek man now for
the next generation you were sawn since
1994 I think McConaughey you are wrong
about George Clooney though let somebody
look that up okay yes he did just in
normal life just like Anderson Cooper
goes over there and dye his hair either
okay reveals why you never who dies here
and yeah again I'll call George myself
fine okay you're one for two men hey but
listen I'm telling you this but here's
this a Warriors were definitely Beatles
Texas Chainsaw Massacre Texas Chainsaw
Massacre could not be redone scarier
than at the 1974 version because it was
the low-budget like horrible acting like
you're right you know I completely agree
it was it was it was like The Blair
Witch experience but it was but it was
real no you know what I'm saying I know
that it's not clear but also watch the
Blair wedge I've not seen the Blair
Witch I watched the blue project lock is
on that he's on this horror movie binge
right and so I'm like so we watched
Blair Witch together and actually the
cinema is that it was all shot on home
video well it was yeah it's actually a
recording of real events oh I'm not
saying that Texas Chainsaw Massacre was
that by any means but I'm saying that it
has that feel because it was done by
like all like borderline amateur
filmmakers like just trying to make it
happen with no money and
outside of Texas and nearly killing each
other trying to make this thing and I
think it translates into the way that
this demented family the actors chose to
act and like I watched the closing scene
right before we came in here and it just
gave me chills because just the
production of it now it's right as scary
film set to be on ya know cuz it was so
they had to get so raw and it's like the
lines between reality and the fiction
were probably at the very blurry at the
very end this like big rig drives up all
the big rig cuz the the bloody girl has
made it to the highway and she's being
chased by the by Leatherface and his
brother and then the rig hits his
brother runs over him and then the got
the rig pulls over and the guy gets out
and then like it's just it's a rig
that's full of chickens Oh a chicken rig
and you know that that was not a
production choice it was like you know
what's the scariest rig we can get the
correct answer is a chicken rig but you
but they don't do that what's the only
really probably they probably flag down
the first rig that came down the road
once they set up the shot and it was
that dude in a chicken rig and they
talked him into being in the movie I
don't know the story but that's what you
could just taste it you taste the
chicken you can taste that chicken rigs
you have you seen that movie where the
guy is being chased by the rig that's a
horror movie he's being chased by the
rig the entire time
it's the guy there's taken exit dude
that's a that sometimes you'll see that
moving on as a TV movie on and it's what
is it guys named Dennis something
Matthew McConaughey but Dennis it's he's
Dennis the big rig he's he is being
sliced I missed the train and there's
also a horror movie about a baboon
called baboon you heard about this one
I just I love I we got to make a horror
movie man we got to do it I think that's
I think that that is the conclusion you
know just George Hill made a blockbuster
horror movie I feel like now I can't
even there same the possibility but I
think but the two of us working to get
you've got the guy who loves to scare
people and the guy who loves to be
scared oh so we work in tandem to dial
it in perfectly we and we make sure it's
got all the elements that oh good great
horror movie should have but it's super
funny it's also a musical because that
hasn't happened in a while
right no come on let's do this okay
let's make a horror movie a horror
musical before we die a horror music
come in on a mini you want to shake on
it what comedy macabre knee you want to
shake on a cop what about dad macabre
knee carbon a comedy my comedy macabre
Dee makka midi makka midi and Matthew
McConaughey's stars oh crap
we're gonna do everything we can to get
Matthew McConaughey in this thing
alright god I'll bet you we could get
John Mayer in it he was in zombeaver
yeah he was wasn't he yeah not one I'd
necessarily recommend alright guys thank
you for hanging with us I hope you
weren't too afraid if you were if you
were listening this whole thing in like
a darkened windowless room with with the
purring chainsaw a meat hook dangling
nearby then good for you for hanging in
there to the end but just think about
the fact that anything is possible
someone could have snuck into your house
while you were listening to this and
that little creek that you heard
downstairs that could be a person or it
could be some sort of supernatural beam
that is ready to infest your soul you're
a jerk man now try to go back to sleep
they weren't trying to go to sleep some
of them were so murder
[Music]